A doctor recently shared a successful story whereby a seizure patient who was experiencing
30 seizures per day took folidic acid according to instructions in the bottle and two weeks later
was not having seizures at all. It isn't best to start small if possible in case there's a reaction
with seizure medication. How will we know if it's working after two weeks? What tests would we need
to check if the possibility of seizures activity? This is a question that I wish I could just answer.
I don't know. It's totally case-dependent. Are you asking should you try folidic acid with
somebody who was currently having seizures? What are they epileptic seizures? Are they having
seizures because of post-concussive issues? Are they having seizures? Are you having seizures?
Grandmull seizures? Are you having teeth seizures? Are you having absent seizures? There's just
a plethora of questions that I have with a question like this that make it impossible to answer.
Things like this really need you need to do a case review with me and we can discuss that if you
really want my help with something like this. If you're interested in getting a case review,
just go to cuntersclinic.com. You can search, you can go to the tab that says schedule now,
you can schedule your own case review complete the whole intake for when we can discuss the full case.
I apologize but this is just not a question that's not really answerable and if the person is having
seizures like anything else you want to get to the reason why you're having seizures and try to deal
with that first. I had patients that had Lyme disease that was causing inflammation of the brain
and were having multiple. I had one young gal who was having over 50 absent seizures a day
as we started working dealing with the cause of the Lyme disease and the inflammation of the brain
she was down to one a day quite quickly and it was just dealing with that cause. So you're always
looking for cause without knowing that because this person did this supplement and got this result
can't I take that supplement and get the same result if I had similar symptoms. Well you can have
similar symptoms that are caused from completely different causes so you want to dig to find out what
that causes.